[Musique]
en 1942 le guide visait à prévenir les
carences nutritionnelles
il fallait aussi améliorer la santé des
canadiens
malgré les rationnements en raison de la
guerre on prêtait également une
attention particulière aux militaires on
voulait avoir des aliments qu'ils font
n'est suffisamment d'énergie donc on
était on était très axé sur la quantité
aussi très axé sur les protéines pour
pouvoir garantir le développement d'une
bonne masse musculaire pour les soldats
on proposait alors six groupes
alimentaires le lait la viande les oeufs
était prépondérant le lait sur tout et
est fortement recommandé et l'huile de
foie de poisson était reconnu comme une
source de vitamine d
en 61 les techniques d'entreposage ont
évolué ainsi que de transport des
aliments
le guide met l'accent sur un plus grand
choix d'aliments les oeufs le fromage et
les pois secs peuvent remplacer la
viande en 1977 le guide subi 30
modifications il n'est plus recommandé
de manger une portion de pommes de terre
par jour
mais ce qui était suggéré autrefois est
écarté c'est que la science évolue et
beaucoup d'aliments sont associés des
maladies quand on regarde les
proportions les volumes des aliments ce
qui fait qu'en 1982 d'autres changements
sont apportés qui prennent en compte les
maladies cardiovasculaires et les
maladies chroniques
avant on donnait des prescriptions donc
des quantités précises à consommer
aujourd'hui on est dans les orientations
dans des repaires généraux puisque on a
compris que ya mille et une façons bien
manger
l'important c'est de respecter des
règles de base qui sont de cuisiner plus
souvent de prendre le temps de manger de
choisir des aliments en moins transformé
un nouveau guide alimentaire canadien a
donc été publié aujourd'hui le 10 ans
plus tard en 1992 nouvelle mouture
quatre groupes alimentaires axée sur les
besoins en nutriments et les apports
énergétiques
mais l'objectif tout au long de ces
années et le même assurer la bonne santé
des canadiens en vo de l'eau des
nutriments
on considère non seulement ce qu'on
mange mais comment on mange donc le fait
de prendre le temps de manger de manger
seul ou en compagnie on est content
aussi de l'environnement naturel donc de
l'impact de notre direct sur
l'environnement
ce guide sert avant tout de référence
pour les établissements publics les
écoles les hôpitaux les prisons mais
c'est combien de partis on a confiance
et il a même été enseigné dans des
établissements scolaires à une certaine
époque tous les pays développés en honte
d'ailleurs l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture recommande un tel outil
pour tous ici catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal